a problem in a puzzle are different
things and a study is a kind of problem
anybody you know there's an entire new
branch it's not new there's a higher
separate branch of chess which is not
about playing but it's about composing
that means you create chess positions
from scratch to try to illustrate some
really beautiful chess teams some of
these are called endgame studies and
those are a lot of the tournament
players favorites because they really
help you with a part of the game that
some people think it's kind of dry the
endgame in fact really one of the most
beautiful parts of the game now some of
these endgame studies and problems are
really wacky and have little relation to
positions that you'll get in your own
game yet
even those are valuable today I'm going
to go over a couple that I think are
really practical that you know could
easily come up in a real game and then
I'll go over a couple that are kind of
the opposite so we'll kind of look at
things from both sides so let's start
with this one and I'm gonna give you
some time and all of them because
they're usually not that easy but would
you have a question this one's white -
move
yeah you're supposed to figure out so
white to move what do you think because
what do you think the result is
I'm not too easy it's actually by an
Israeli composer and he composed one of
my favorite problems actually that's not
what not it I this is cool but I think
this is more of like a practical side
like this is something that you could
kind of come up with in a real game
because in general these types of
positions with I think one of the most
underrated positions and games to study
in chess is end games with works against
pawns because they kind of come up a lot
that you have a rock and your opponent
has a couple pawns and you have to see
whether that work can stop them or not
do Paretsky
has a great endgame book and there is a
big big chunk in that but I think in
general people ignore them a little bit
compared to their importance like
there's a lot of stuff about pawning
games and there's a lot of stuff about
working Ponting games but rookworst pawn
end games not quite as much as there
should be in my view so King f5 ok
that's a good idea but what if I take
the pawn with the King instead now
because you just play King at 5 so my
Kings on 8 6 and you just played King fi
so now I can play King takes g7 so
that's the problem so basically you're
trying to like ways to move and
unfortunately King at 5 is not a pure
waste of a move so just let me give a
couple of moves here so g7 checked so
that we are on the same page cuz I know
everybody in this class is kind of at a
different level but one of the nice
things about in games this is a bit of
an equalizer like if you're just
starting out and you work hard and you
try to clear your brain you can be just
as good as a way more experienced player
and in games same is not in true with
openings and middle games because it's a
lot more about experience as well as
trying hard in those phases in game is a
bit unique in that way so g6 check King
eight six now the suggestion of King f5
unfortunately fails to King g7 and we
also had your suggestion which was just
King at 7:00
unfortunately that fails too right
because now we get to take this with
check which leaves you no time to make a
queen which I'm sure is what you wanted
to do right so instead wait to move yeah
so yes if we Queen the pawn here black
must do I take so notice how almost all
these moves are forced by white that's
the kind of nice thing about
endgame studies it makes you look at all
of the moves even if they seem bizarre
right like you wouldn't want to look at
8 equals Queen giving up your queen in
your prized pawn but you just look at
every other move and they all lost so
you might as well look at that right
it's called process of elimination and
it really does make sense if you think
of it that way right you looked it
there's one move two moves they both
lose so you look at the third move right
and that's why if it's you can solve
these studies and these problems easier
than you think because they seem really
difficult but after work takes Queen now
what on earth can white do because it
looks like they're just gonna lose right
so they better step to it if they want
to have any chance to save this game it
looks like blacks just going to come in
and win the pawns in the game right if
you were black in this position that was
your move what would you do yes
exactly beautiful you play we're t8 and
then you just take both pawns the end
you know how to mate with the rook
where's the king right
do you work first King you sure could
you beat Magnus Carlsen
with a rook where's a king how many
people you're good beaten Magnus Carlsen
with work first King all right yes you
can all right let's see the point is
that when you have a rook or a queen
versus a king you should know that in
game so well that you can beat anyone
with it it is kind of important anyway
so we're t8 the threat so white must
play wot again process of elimination a
very difficult problem that anyone can
solve if you use this process of
elimination thinking virtue a is a
threat we don't have very many moves so
what would you play yeah well let's try
King f7 seems like they're really only a
possibility the other only other real
move that like doesn't anything is
making a queen so let's try it King at 7
at least now we have a threat right of G
8 equals Queen right so now we have a
threat to them immediately draw the game
with that move so what would black have
to play here work a 7 check now what do
you think the big idea is here for white
let's see somebody else I'm Dylan I'm
sorry in the name you wrote your name in
the back Elliott ok sorry hmm that
blacks idea right so what would like you
what's a white the big idea here to try
to like save this game perhaps yes we do
have a stalemate idea at the end very
good but what would you play is right
here so King G a and now if rook takes
g7 and our
yeah exactly so King to h8 now and
notice that if the rook or the King
takes on g6 it's Wyatt it's just an
instant draw right skill me no moves
right okay see that this is a very very
common endgame tracked it comes up a lot
so I would categorize this is one of
those and game studies that's really
practical because you solve it but you
also learn something now one important
point
what if black plays work to a seven
instead now what should white do
again perhaps of elimination just like
140 move what would you do here yes who
said it so raise your hand somebody else
raise your hand I have what happens here
what's the forcing way to finish this
game how about somebody who I haven't
called on yet somebody new just want to
make sure everybody is following so
repeating the same how about in that row
back there is anybody see it here 2nd
row what we must play here to score the
immediate draw exactly g7 and now we're
threatening g8 so they have to take and
again it's a stalemate alright so this
is a type of a problem and I love to
study with my students and myself
because not only does it help with your
it helps with your imagination as well
as your calculation and both of those
things are pretty important in jazz now
yeah I need to flip the board every time
what happened yeah all right now this
one is a little different in that I
would I would categorize this one that
it's not quite as practical but it's
really fun so what would you do here is
why it you're gonna love this one
this one's not easy at all so what you
want to do again is look at all of your
possible moves again these types of
positions can be a big equalizer because
even if you haven't studied chess really
seriously it's all about looking at all
of your possible moves and then trying
to analyze the tree of each one but
let's take a little longer
this one's really a little very
difficult so you might want to just like
make sure you're looking at all the
different possibilities before you pick
one
now clearly I mean within this one we're
trying to win his wife because if we
were trying to draw we have a month
bunch of different ways to draw right
like work takes night it is one idea but
work takes a a night takes a a DIN king
takes a seven right there's no way
there's no way blacks gonna win that
right but they can play they can't play
King takes c6 so that after King takes a
a you can't you can't escape that on
this is like again this is actually very
practical this is a really important
thing Knight takes a a King takes a
seven now if King takes c6 can takes a
eight well there's just king b5 but even
if we didn't have king b5 like suppose
our suppose the pawn was like one
further on a sex this is still a draw
because the white king can escape that's
really important right so just to
illustrate like say it's like this right
notice that one we put this King here
there's nothing they can do because if
they put their pawn on a7
it's again a stalemate right and if they
go here what would you do is black you
must play King CA right if you play King
see this year you're leaving them in
this cage right this is a little cage
with just two steps if you make this
move it's a massive blunder because now
what can white do and and this is seems
very simple but I'll tell you what comes
up in every game you know especially if
you're in a blitz time scramble at the
end it's so easy to make mistakes with
this exact position yes exactly it came
to be eight and now it's actually White
who wins the game
so Winston right
Wilson you're Winston okay I don't but
you knew that too right Winston you know
so what else can we do here
so we're take say it only leads to a
draw but that variation is very
instructive so that's why I mean like
you get to look at these really cool
variations but you also it's like you're
eating your you have like your your real
basic nutritional stuff here and that
like that last variation that's very
nutritious you need that to get better
in to be a proficient endgame pyre and
then you have your dessert as well which
there's some like really beautiful
variations that we're about to say but
you need to find whites continuation
this is absolutely amazing see you like
it yes we can look at it so you're
thinking if pawn takes Knight here now
you're basically thinking that they're
gonna have to take here and you're
thinking that you're gonna be able to
come in with your pawns and beat me
right there is a little bit of a problem
with that what did you want to play
there so you want to take the a pawn
with what the king of the pond okay now
if you take what the pond I have a good
move here well I guess it's kind of
forest one might work also actually
maybe I'm wrong that it's forest yeah I
think rook e1 works too and then the
idea is just if you queen we check after
here rook takes a a now King takes a a
king cake c6 nobody wins right that's a
problem so you're very very close like
if you had one more won't move you would
win that right and unfortunately for you
King takes a seven also doesn't work
because now what can black black rook
takes b6 wouldn't work because then King
takes b6 and the pawns gonna make a
queen but what can black play instead
here which salvage is the draw what do
you think
exactly what we could to actually take
on c6 right yes and now if they take
this we do what and then it's just again
king verse king nobody went that right
so a very close try Winston but a lot of
times Winston and Wilson but the problem
is in these endgame studies a lot of
times these obviously key moves like one
takes b6 they don't cut the mustard
usually it's something more spectacular
or that I save today
so what's a spectacular way for white to
win and why Elliot
okay what's your certain emote with the
aid it's good to look at every single
possible move but that one doesn't that
worked at the eight we're taking d8 and
it's tough to come up with a
continuation they're not what b7
although that is interesting
yeah I mean I guess the problem is we
can just take on c6 in these variations
you know yeah okay yeah you process of
elimination we tried everything so we
better try c7 especially because it's a
4c move right it's always good to look
at the force name moves here because if
c7 it's pretty clear now that we've got
two massive threats right rook takes a
eight Knight takes a eight Queen
so you don't really have a lot of choice
here for black if you're black here you
have to play why well work takes work
just allows quantex be a equals Queen
right so basically the only move here
for black is why King takes pawn yes and
then I challenge you to figure out what
white can do then so now let's take a
look I think now we're close enough that
maybe some of us can get it let's think
a little bit longer so if King takes e7
okay yeah the idea is after kim takes e7
what is exactly so you're saying after
kim taek's c7 work take c8 night takes a
king takes a7 there's no way in okay but
there it but that's why you have to find
something better for right so King take
c7 white to move and win I'll give you
this move okay I fine so yeah you get to
see it from this position white to move
and win now somebody sees a I don't see
anyone's hand nobody's hand is up hmm
but there is it there is a very
beautiful one here which I promise you
will never come up in a game but
everything else we looked at will this
will probably not okay
well I'll be very excited if it comes up
in one ear game you'll have to email me
it's it's extremely unusual I've never
seen it before very very rare idea here
for white soap on date night check and
then and then what would what would
black do yes you can take the work with
the King Quan takes funds not going to
go too well because if pawn takes pawn
then you just play work takes a 8 right
exactly yeah so it's a very very unusual
idea excellent so you start red pawn
takes b6 check and note that this pawn
can't capture on b6 because then work
takes a8 right so that would just be a
work first upon so instead you must look
at after pawn takes b6 you must look at
this move King takes rock right but now
white can play the move what move can
white plate here Winston what can we
play here white were you listening ok
very good b7 what's that yes we're
trapping the rook but even worse if
black could just say pass here that
would be pretty good right pass I don't
want to make a move that okay exactly
that's right exactly so what is this
called if we could pass our position
would be fine but we must make a move
what is that called Elliot
zooks Wang very good zigs and zigs Wang
is one of the coolest concepts in chess
it's a really important concept than the
endgame it almost never comes up in the
middle game there is a famous stop
position or two where there's legs long
in the middle game but it's usually
reserved for the end game in the opening
in the middle game 98% of the time it's
good for us to have a move right we want
to have moves we have lots of stuff that
we can do that helps our position the
end game is the exception where
sometimes having a move hurt sauce and
this is a case right here because we
really would just like to stick this
King here so that after pawn takes King
takes right but instead we must move our
King up to c7 and now of course we make
a queen and we win the game shortly
thereafter so any questions about that
position but uh I I love I love how it
kind of combines the practical and the
spectacular which is you can't really
get much more from that in a study ok
let's start with this one so this one is
way too mu
work do you on why oh I thought you said
D I think somebody said D somebody in
the front row city yeah works in d1 and
why work d1 because I point us no checks
exactly it gives YT no good checks right
we can't really check on d8 we can't
check on d5 and now meanwhile black is
starting to play why just to Queen upon
with h1 so then what would Y do
No let's try to try to figure that out
so everybody I'm going to put I'm going
to put the position out on the board
actually alright so now white to move
anybody you see what to do here for
white because blacks just 20 to make a
queen and then after Queen takes Queen
rook takes Queen check they'll take our
pawn off and that won't be good exactly
so you're trying to play Queen h1
sacrificing your queen and now what rook
takes Queen what can we do yes
push the pawn and now if we play here
what's the difference
exactly we get a check here that's right
and then after they play something like
that they have to move their King over
what can we do now what's the best move
yeah exactly Queen the b8 hitting the
King and hitting upon and then white
wound up winning that how many people
here can win with a queen Versa rock
that one is a little harder than rook
bursting especially if you're playing
against a computer
luckily against humans it's pretty easy
because everybody hangs a rook
eventually but it's true I mean it
sounds really bad but it's true it's
like it's just very difficult the
computers are just really notorious at
that end game but it's almost impossible
to defend for like a normal person so
what we're going to do with this one is
I'm gonna have you guys play it out so
that we can get our hands dirty
one thing that we'll teach you is if you
do have a really tough problem go back
to the old fashioned chessboard in chess
set don't study everything on your
computer even Magnus Carlsen studies
with a chess board and a chess set some
of the top players in the world only
study on the computer but I really think
it's more fun to occasionally set
positions up like this and a chess board
because that's how you're gonna be
playing your most important games so I'm
not saying doing it 100% of the time
because if you did 100% of the time you
wouldn't be getting in enough volume
like if you want to study like 100
tactics in a week you don't have to
setup a hundred different positions
right you want to do some of them on the
computer but
top ones get out your boredom pieces
okay how many people already do that
okay good - you're ahead of the game but
I was really shocked at how much quicker
you guys got this just by setting it off
it's really amazing many of you solved
the position quickly whereas if I gave
you two minutes to solve it up here I
don't think that would have happened
maybe but probably not
so g7 and now work to see to check which
is a key move here so that the king of
blocks that path of the pond right so
after King be a rook G to stop me in the
other pond now b7 rook takes pawn and
now we recognize this position for more
of the problems we looked at earlier in
the class right very similar situation
where White has to play wat okay how
many people got to this position okay
good I know you two back there did all
three of you back there did ya well got
to this position and then somehow some
people got to a position where okay so
we're things b7 is going to be an
immediate draw right so blacks going to
try to win all right so he's gonna play
work g8 and said now this is where a lot
of you got thrown off big time a lot of
you thought that the solution now for
white was to make a knight here right
how many people try that I saw at least
two or three people trying that
but what T can you guys try that I
thought you did you did yeah but that's
a good idea it's very good to be
creative and think about that but the
problem is it's just not the right one
here because yeah I mean if we if we
play here then there's no moves for
Wyatt right but um if we play which
would be good because white wants a draw
but if they just play here then you're
in a sticky situation right because now
White has to play
and now what come back through yeah you
have to calculate this out but it looks
like black White's gonna be one move too
slow here are cracks look at that what's
that well the other thing is here you
don't even need to take this night so
you can also just check here I mean
you're gonna be winning this with the
extra pot I mean I wouldn't even
honestly I wouldn't even calculate it
rook takes Knight just in case I'm wrong
I think it's kind of silly when you can
just play rook g2 and win the pawn and
then just cause immediate resignation
it's just not very practical
right in fact I think that's really an
important lesson like it requires a lot
of a lot more work to do that whereas
you can just play work g2 and work takes
h2 and win absolutely in your sleep
right like everybody will win that
position now that doesn't mean that you
shouldn't calculate work takes b8 for
practice but in a practical game if it's
that easy to just win another piece you
really want to be doing that right so
make sense but white can make it a lot
harder by instead of making a knight
making one no just like making a queen
and forcing them to take off right I
mean just simple chests because if you
think about it Knight the only thing it
does is that the other move doesn't do
is check but it still gives you the
option of playing work takes b8 except
it also gives black the option of
playing King b5 right whereas Queen
doesn't do any of that right it just
forces work kp8 does that make sense
guys and now after King b8 can be stakes
this is a really important position what
should black what's a white do what do
you think
okay why not king CA what happens if
king CA somebody try to play this out
for me as black somebody play black
black for me here
Elliot you want to try playing this for
me for black somebody else yeah okay
king c6 now suppose I play here okay
suppose I play here okay well at some
point you should probably okay okay
No yeah good very good
so optical illusion there it looks like
you're gonna be fast enough and that
very it looks like it's gonna be the
same but really it's not right
so somebody want to show me the right
way somebody else so I know how you got
it somebody want to try now for white
the right way Telly's you want to play
out for white
okay so keen a eight instead right
that's for starters and now I want to
make progress for it's going to this
pawn I guess I should go there now I
it's very key there's a very key square
that you want to reach all to me I
wouldn't ask where that white ultimately
wants to reach air what's the key square
after all right so what is that fastest
path back to Wilson
Winston okay good and now suppose we go
here
mm-hmm
that's right you're there just in time
so see that one difference in move gave
white that that tempo needed to a very
instructive position which started all
the way over here where there's that
like a little optical illusion because
this looks closer to this than that but
in reality it's this key square over
here that we need to get to to go down
there and this doesn't help us right so
it's a really bizarre illusion almost
that it's easier to see like just by
playing out right you can't really
absorb it visually so well but um yeah
great job guys I hope you learned
something and really important in that
that endgame there in the end where the
black has to get to kick back to to make
the draw or f1 is very very common
so all this like cool stuff around it
that's like the study problem where the
composer makes it look beautiful but
that final stuff will come up in in game
after endgame